[Applause]
yes
all right
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all right
happy Thursday the 13th it's like Friday
the 13th but sexier
but hey looks like it's time for
if you're obsessed with crime it's the
perfect time you'll get off scot-free
and every damn City and for all you
squares out there say Above The Fray
let's summarizes
it's crime Roundup Thursday just flows
right off the tongue there
first let's go to The View
where I'd like to report a murderer
uh I was fired from the five I had a
very toxic relationship with another of
the cast members which one
I may I may get there I may get there
and also I thought that it was very
unfair that I was not judged objectively
in our disputes but rather he was always
favored hmm
no no no no poor thing in lieu of
flowers we set up a GoFundMe page to get
him a barber
but I credit the view for finally
finding a guest with a bigger mustache
than their panelists
[Applause]
they're a hairy bunch
California where Dems just blocked a
bill to make child trafficking a serious
felony why would you do that it would
have punished criminals convicted of
child trafficking with 25 to life in
prison but the Dems in the assembly
actually blocked it and why they were
worried it might lead to longer
sentences
isn't that the point you've you idiots
you want a dumb sentence you dumb
pedophile supporting child mutilating
criminal ass kissing overtastic
drug addicts three Poopers you are
putting innocent children in danger
I got it I got calmed down now let's go
to NYC where Manhattan D.A and human Hot
Pocket Alvin Bragg admits even his
policies put his own children his own
children in danger
I know the statistics at Transit crime
is down but when one of my family
members gets on the train I too get a
knot in my stomach
in his stomach you should be grateful
it's not a bullet
he's putting his own kids in danger to
support a destructive ideology that is
some Dad if anyone deserves to be mugged
by reality it's him but it never is him
or anybody like him it's always someone
else
meanwhile a new poll reveals 87 percent
of New Yorkers say crime is a serious
problem the other 13 were already
murdered
but they're not waiting around for help
anymore 40 are buying security systems
Firearms tasers pepper spray and signing
up for self-defense classes and some are
dressing like this to ward off attackers
but talk about a lose-lose if they're
unsuccessfully defending themselves they
die and if they win they're going to go
to jail for manslaughter and you can
guess who New York city mayor Eric Adams
blames for all this here's a hint not
Eric Adams he says crime itself isn't a
problem the fact that you know about the
crime is Because unless you've already
been murdered you probably start your
day picking up the news
they start their day picking up the uh
the news of the morning papers they sit
down and they see some of the most
horrific events that may happen
throughout the previous day it plays on
your psyche
first of all the morning paper
what is this
1977. I mean yeah that's my morning I
walk outside to get the morning paper
and hopefully the Milkman has already
come then I go back inside and I turn my
butter
but it's our fault for reading the
stories no dude it's not like crime
reporting is a brand new idea from the
2020s it was there under Bloomberg and
Giuliani there was just less of it
because there was less crime the mayor
says it's the media creating the
perception that's
post George Floyd the media buried all
the stats on crime and even lied about
the explosion in crime if the media had
actually done their job how many lives
do you think would have been saved I
mean do I have to play this damn tape
again to remind you how much they
gaslighted a country
if you watch a certain State TV and you
listen to conservative media you would
think that you know entire cities are
just you know in broadened fights and
fires and whatever we went out had a
great dinner in New York City tonight
people actually walked up to us and said
thank you New York City was not um you
know hellscape they just squawked up and
said thank you you're a lying blood
covered
[Applause]
slave
but as bad as things are in New York
City at least we got one thing going for
us we're not Chicago
hell I think people say that in
Mogadishu
Chicago crime spiked by almost 90
percent since 2021 the good news they
got rid of that day walking bug eye
drool dripping Goblin the bad news is
the new guy he might be worse
Chicago mayor Brandon Johnson just
released a thick report titled the
blueprint for creating a more just and
vibrant City for all and if you think
his blueprint includes stopping crime
you're nuts in fact Mayor Johnson wants
to reduce crime fighting due to its
racial disparities
but what if some races for whatever
reason commit more crimes do we
completely stop punishing those crimes
to come to a number where we're all the
same that doesn't make any sense and
they say rampant crime is caused by over
policing but crime skyrocketed when the
police were defunded just as we
predicted and yet they lie and the media
continues to let them lie just look at
this from that same report quote it's
hard to trust people who don't look like
you
the mayor of Chicago actually said that
to his constituents but blacks aren't
being killed in overwhelming numbers by
whites they're being killed by other
blacks people who look like you mayor
some
it's got to speak up for these victims
because pretty soon we're gonna run out
of them
tonight yes
she Moonlight has a Keebler Elm co-host
of America's Newsroom in the five dado
burrito
you might recognize him from the cover
of white privilege magazine Fox News
contributor Tom shaloo
hecklers because they usually have
better material comedian Joe DeVito
[Applause]
and finally she's like a Post-It note
small thin and sticks to most surfaces
[Applause]
hi Dana how you doing great how are you
hi I'm fantastic do you care to comment
about this morning's episode of The View
or shall we just ignore it like a piece
of Filth drifting down the sidewalk no
need to punch down yeah why shall we
punch that we shall not although I do it
every day that's how I get my exercise
punching down can I say that Geraldo not
being comfortable with on-air friction
yes this was a show do you remember his
syndicated yeah my next guest is a black
guy and a klansman yeah
[Laughter]
so
I mean this guy makes Jerry Springer
look like the Algonquin Table
[Laughter]
what do you make of these excuses that
these politicians are making a lot of
politicians will always blame the media
right and that's I think it's just so
despicable it's not true and now you can
blame the media for being biased about
things and you can also blame the media
for ignoring a story so for example and
maybe we'll talk about it here but
um the hunter Biden Story the media has
been very curious curiously
intellectually I'm curious right about
this whole thing now for mayor Adams
it's like turning into Lori Lightfoot
right because she started to blame the
media as well it's like if you guys are
just covering the bad news and I know
politicians get frustrated Biden's
frustrated because he's saying guys
don't you see that price of eggs are
down why don't you think the economy's
so much better mayor Adams said I don't
want people my job is to make people
feel different than how they feel but
people feel how they feel because of
everything that's around them it's not
just what they see on the news it's
their lived experience yeah and I think
the other thing that's happening in New
York and maybe in other cities as well
these fine folks could tell us is that
you see what's happening media then you
walk across Times Square three times as
I did the other night and it was
shocking yeah it's just so embarrassing
for the city and then you find out that
in the morning at 10 A.M there's a guy
with a knife threatening people in Times
Square yes it was Paul Hogan that wasn't
Fox News 5 Fox News fault yes that they
covered it's not the New York Post fault
that they covered it's them for not
doing something especially because on
the recurrent robberies we know it's 500
people or fewer yeah so arrest them
prosecute them deal with the issue yeah
Tom um as a white collar criminal you're
probably relieved that all this other
violence is happening that's true uh you
know I think this these cities New York
City and our other cities are becoming
kind of ungovernable and people are
starting to think oh we can't go back we
can because it isn't as bad as it was
when I first moved here to New York but
you know what happened then in the early
90s we had the guardian angels remember
Curtis sliwell of course and this is
when citizens were taking vigil
anti-action and they weren't walking
around with weapons they just went in
and they were guardian angels I would
love to join the guardian angels not
because I'm tough but because I look
great in a beret
but the Monica Lewinsky yeah
[Applause]
when citizens started doing that it was
like the politicians didn't like it then
either yeah and the police didn't like
the chief of police at the time they
didn't like the guardian angels and the
the politicians didn't like the guardian
angels why because it was an
embarrassment because citizens were
having to protect themselves but what
that did seeing those Guardian Angels
made New Yorkers wake up and they said
you know what why aren't our politicians
able to handle this and we elected
Giuliani we had Chief Bratton and we
changed things so things can go back
it's just that people have to be
motivated so maybe we need the guardian
angels once again that's a terrible
[Applause]
[Music]
of a vigilante group yeah especially if
it's the same Guardian Angels we're in
their 70s now yes
all right they're like Pacino and
Godfather Three
oh you want me back in I'm drooling so
tell me Joe Joe are you scared to come
to work
well yeah but it's mostly because of the
people I encounter when I'm here yes
good and hard what they voted for
because Lori Lightfoot left them some
tiny little shoes to fill because she's
strange little elf-like creature but uh
this blueprint for the city it's more
like a chalk outline for Chicago at this
point uh and and it's they seem shocked
at the idea that if you do not imprison
criminals you you don't positively
affect the crime rate it's ridiculous
that they they don't they don't see the
connection between their policies yes
and then what happens and we're starting
to see it in New York now too and it's
it's really unfortunate the big cities
don't have to be this way but like Tom
said it's a small group of people who
cause most of the trouble put them in
jail and you see the rap sheets and you
think why is this person out and you can
tell that as soon as you start to read
the story and when they talk about
um wanting to do anytime you see social
justice you know it's not what that
shows up that means a person's a scale a
real criminal like somebody really bad
when they go he's being released because
social because you know it's social
justice and you're going oh God no this
person's gonna reoffend cat
at
what does that would brag piss you off
talking about how he is nervous about
being on the subway after he helped
release every offender on the subway I
think a lot of people are nervous
because the traffic is like out of
control that's true you know I like
nobody's punching me in the face because
I'm in a car but sometimes you feel like
you wish they would yeah because it took
me 15 minutes to go two blocks and I
think that these are things that people
notice I think everything you can make
the connection they're doing that
because they're not taking the subway I
think so yeah and I think people are
afraid I think that people who live here
they're not concerned about it being
politicized same thing as in California
with this child sex trafficking Bill
where someone was like well we don't
want to negatively impact these
disadvantaged communities I'm like if
you're trafficking kids I'm cool with
you having some disadvantages thrown
your way yeah who they who do they
protecting Gavin Newsom actually went
against them and was like oh you know I
think this is good it's like imagine
that being like so bold to go with the
other party on such a contentious issue
apparently of trafficking kids yes and
by the way we're not talking about Good
trafficking right like getting them
across the street this is bad
trafficking
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else